there's one thing I feel with people
that follow all these different videos
online especially value team and being
one of them is to think it is so easy to
become an entrepreneur I don't want to
mislead you for you to think this is
easy the game of entrepreneurship is
very very hard this is why only a few
choose to become entrepreneurs and the
majority are wanting to stay on the
sidelines playing it safe
just keep that part of mine so a lot of
people I want to wear these I'm an
entrepreneur and I'm about to be an
entrepreneur you got to know one thing
here and that is if you don't handle
pressure you're going to end up on this
side very quickly this is why there's a
few on this side it's because they learn
how to handle pressure this is not just
in a game of business look in the game
of baseball sports I remember one time
many many years ago I used to go to
Dodger games I was 13 14 years old and I
went to a game against Houston Astros
back in the days the squad was Jeff
Bagwell Craig Biggio Ken Caminiti Kevin
bass and I like the Houston Astros team
at that time and one of my favorite
plays was Ken Caminiti and I will never
forget as a kid Ken Caminiti was a
left-handed third baseman here I think
41 hormones one season just a beautiful
swing yet I go afterwards
and I'm with Kevin bass I'm talking to
Kevin bass Ken Caminiti is to my left he
starts crying and hugging this lady 15
minutes he's crying while he's hugging
this lady and I watch the saying oh my
gosh what is going on here and all she
was saying is begging him to stop
drinking or whatever it was fast forward
a few years later you know what happened
to Ken Caminiti he ends up dying this
story I have personal friends that this
happens I just had one that happened two
to three weeks ago same exact scenario
I'm telling you because why because of
this subject of pressure so Hollywood
happens all the time business happens
all the time sports it happens all the
time this happens all the time
so I want to put a formula behind it
we're going to be able to say okay cool
I kind of know how to handle pressure
nice that's the lesson guarantee you're
going to make it in business I just want
to kind of give you an idea what could
possibly take place with you so at times
the price you're going to face in
business let's go through a few of them
one of them is fast success fast money I
got a snapchat earlier today from a kid
21 year old kid
is what the snap says pad I'm 21 years
old I just made 1 million dollars this
year I am so afraid what should I do
he's never made that kind of money his
parents have never made that kind of
money and let on making a death pass at
21 years old that is pressure some
people that I love that that kind of a
pressure it's still pressure
personal life issues pressure you having
a relationship doesn't work out how do
you bring it in business and you're
still trying to close a deal but you got
a relationship with your wife dad mommy
husband you know kids all this other
stuff getting suit it's going to happen
a business losing talent to another
company it's going to happen in business
you know a big order canceled somebody
ordered with you a hundred thousand
dollars you're excited you about to get
the order going they cancel it with you
you don't know what to do you sold the
house you sold an insurance policy you
got a social media contract with a
client and they cancel it you don't a
handle hand with that that's pressure
media bashing you negatively pressure
new competitor new threat taking over
your position
security breach somebody comes in into
your system and finds all these social
securities all this that's happening a
lot recently ideas stolen backstabbing
deadlines deadlines brings a lot of
pressure to people I had somebody just
yesterday told me to send an email this
person said to me in an email saying I
can't necessarily promise you what I'm
going to get done by the end of this
month but I'm going to do my best
because there's way too many variables I
said you can say that if you're doing me
a favor but you can't say that if I'm
paying you for it if I'm paying you for
it there is a deadline you got to get it
done but some people can't handle that
pressure that's the world of business
the world of business isn't this rare I
exciting let me go be a millionaire
drive nice cars and impress people and
girls want to flirt with me that's not
the world of business just so you
understand this there's a real
legitimate part of business that you
need to how to handle this so that means
a lot of friction crisis sometimes you
feel like it's the end of the world and
you start asking these strange questions
can I do this right you hit this wall
boom you're by yourself can I do this do
I make the right there did I make the
right decision by taking money out of my
401k starting a business some people do
that did I make the right decision of
even getting into this industry did I
make the right decision quitting my job
what if I fail what will people think of
me alas
but not least where is the smallest hole
in the wall hole doesn't have a W
where's the smallest hole in the wall
for me to hide in how can I get away
from everybody and hide in it I don't
want anybody to see me I want to be
alone don't call me don't talk to me
leave me alone this sucks
why boom pressure Dwight Gooden pressure
Robert Downey jr. pressure fast success
but he recovered LeBron James pressure
for the first many years can't win he
won Kobe Bryant pressure after Colorado
he recovered Darryl Strawberry pressure
you got what's the other guys invest in
diamond I think from back in the days
from screecher pressure this is all
different types of pressure that you're
going to be getting all of it so what do
you do so now the question okay Pat how
do I handle this pressure I just signed
an agreement with a big publishing
company and they wanted me to write a
book on how to process issues because
I've said this for now two three years
on video but I've been saying this for a
long time if you work with me directly
the number one skill set anybody can
learn in their lifetime it's to learn
how to process issues you learn how to
process issues you're going straight to
the top if you're not afraid of working
hard and knowing clearly what you want
so I'm writing a book on exactly how to
process issues and I'm getting detailed
to the steps where you can actually
quantify it sit down and say this is
exactly how I'm going to do this and I'm
giving you a ton of content in this book
won't be coming up for 18 months I'm not
selling any books today I'm just telling
you I'm working on that right now what's
the process step number one first
question you get ask yourself is what's
the worst case scenario what's the worst
thing that could happen right so
sometimes my friends are afraid of
getting married and I asked her what's
the worst case scenario what is the
worst case scenario in this situation
here the guy's going to leave you yes
can you handle that what so what can you
handle that I don't know if I can handle
that why don't you know you're not
prepared to lead what's the worst case
scenario could you lose that customer
yes can you handle that I think I could
handle it's going to suck but I can help
get them great what's the worst case you
always go to the worst-case worst case
marriage doesn't work out worst case I
file bankruptcy worst case always go to
worst case and if you go to worst case
you can accept worst case then come back
you've already accepted this very rarely
is this going to happen you can handle
all the other things that's going to
come up to your right step number two
its control and when I say control it's
very simple what can you control with
this issue and pressure you're facing
what can you not control make a list of
things you cannot control I don't even
want to spend a thing at a second
thinking about it what do you control
spend time looking at this year once you
make a list of things that you can
control on the problems that you're
facing
next is qualifying it what is qualifying
okay I got seven things that I can
control what's the most important this
is important that is important this is
important the other four they're really
issues but they're not really that
issues I take top three then I finalize
it and bring you down to one the top
issue prioritizing the cause of the
number one issue then I ask what is
causing this and I ask so many why why
why did it's that but why did that
happen what causes why why why until I
go to the deepest why then you solve the
deepest why once you solve the deepest
why that data then it comes over here
and the pressure you say this is what
I'm facing it is what it is we'll
overcome it and we'll move on and then
you move on and by the way just so you
know your income level the people that
make more money they make more money
because they can handle more pressure
that's why they make more money in
sports a guy that can take the last shot
bottom of the ninth he can handle it
pressure in business boardroom quarterly
calls investors pressure in in the arena
of politics or the arena of military
pressure
whoever can handle pressure the best the
most ends up winning and this is why I
tell you and I said I don't want to miss
leave you the world of business is very
ugly the world of business is going to
have a lot of people out there that are
going to come after you but if you
create a system and figure out a way to
handle pressure and you put your work
ethic where you going out and come to
trying to figure out ways to improve and
you put in a work ethic there and it's
important to you you will eventually
possibly have a shot at doing this and
the reason why talk about this because
if you don't know handle pressure this
is what typically leads to Vice
now I don't want to spend a lot of time
talking about bikes but I'm talking
about drugs alcohol ecstasy's antics
paying you know vicodin
pot cocaine you know gambling secret
gambling habits this leads to all of
that stuff because there's an escape
from the actual pressure that people
want to handle so to them this is an
escape this is an escape this is an
escape you know going out there and
gambling in is an escape from what the
actual reality is you create this you
know handle this you want to have to
have a vice because your vice is trying
to play this game of business scheme you
can handle it or not so again going back
to it watch this video again figure out
one of the issues you're facing right
now that's putting a lot of pressure in
your life use this questionnaire solve
it and see what your deepest Y is and
then based on that start working on
fixing the deepest Y so with that being
said if you have any questions comments
thoughts comment on the bottom and if
you haven't subscribed to this channel
yet click on the subscribe button here
and if you're not part of the
notification squad click on a
notification squad to be one the first
to get this video every time it comes
out take everybody by
[Music]